[Musique]
c'est un grand bond soir que nous vous
disons les enfants car nous partons en
voyage ce soir oui et nous ramenons pas
pr neil nicolas chez eux je descend vite
les cherchez pas trop mon l'échelle hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop à la la la
la la la la la la la la la
la la la la la la la la la la la la la
la la la la la la la
manama la même à la meilleure
mama mama mama la manade
[Musique]
robot bon choix
bonsoir camarades bonsoir mon cher tata
ou bien les enfants je vois que vous
avez fait votre valise
et la roulotte est bien en ordre ce soir
nous aussi on part en voyage au lever du
soleil
nous partons par les grands chemins nous
éclairer s'est produit nous vous dirons
nous serons et pipita tpiy tu as voyages
ou si siné route c'est une enfant de la
balle notre pépite à
[Musique]
c'est promis les enfants mais avant de
nous quitter si nous faisions une auront
oui à
la ronde du rosier
mongi à quatre fleurs au velours on joue
mon aussi un 4 fleurs d'une charmante
aux couleurs quand la nuit est arrivé au
le bleu le rouge quand la nuit est
d'arriver meilleur transfert monde ainsi
que
messieurs mais moi quand j'étais défini
2,4 et cognition non-cadres champignons
non notre boutures ou
mademoiselle les et messieurs mes
boutons de rose dans ce tous les cadres
entre eux et les cadres merveilleux
quand le soleil est levé le projet cela
va leur bout du nez dans la rosée
partenaires mais voilà que le barbouillé
pour le reste la journée
l'écossé
à
[Musique]
présent cheikh anta je vous fais mes
adieux et vous souhaite bonne route
tous mes voeux vous accompagne mon ami
au revoir mon petit cornichons à bientôt
comme les champs à bientôt madame beau
voyage
les départs
c'est toujours émouvant au revoir ma
petite pépite
offre un pépites à
[Musique]
c'est gentil de nous ramener du marchand
de sable vous allez faire la vitesse un
petit peu oui vous n'avez pas peur non
moi j'ai jamais peur au gouvernement
toute épreuve
et l'état va vite chez kornit chaud il
tâte au
1 route
bonne nuit tous nos amis
attendons
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]